yeah ever happened to you that you were
playing ill during the tournaments or
withdrew from the tournament have this
ever happened to you before uh once I
was on the verge of withdrawing I got a
food poisoning a terrible food poisoning
in Mexico City
in7 the world championship mhm and
um I decided to play but uh throughout
the tournament I would be just crying I
I uh I I would be just uh you know
getting in the resting area and just oh
my God just to cry cuz I was feeling so
sick I I got um I think I got some sort
of a disent oh my gosh this was really
and you still kept
playing yes yes but just players they
never give up you know they always keep
playing I remember myself fever whatever
I would still come and play well you
know this was the my first candidates